hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
this is the weekly podcast where I Hank
green and usually John Green but this
week Emma blackery answer your questions
give you dubious advice and bring you
all the week's news from both Mars and
AFC Wimbledon but first Emma have a poem
for us I do I decided I would fill in
for John and and give a nice romantic
sort of poem and I'm gonna dedicate it
to John I think I think he'll enjoy this
one
um okay are you ready yes okay Daniel my
brother you are older than me do you
still feel the pain of the scars that
won't heal your eyes have died but you
see more than I Daniel you're a star in
the face of the sky Thank You Emma I'm
glad this is becoming a tradition as
long as John is gone all of the poems
will be Bernie Taupin lyrics is a man
who wrote almost all of John songs
thanks to Maureen Johnson for starting
off that tradition and thank you Emma
for continuing it oh it's a legacy now
so for everyone who doesn't know Emma
blackery is a youtuber and a musician
and you you're something of an advice
giver yourself so I'm excited too lucky
me on the show tell us about yourself uh
okay jeez and I always hate that
question so tell us I how could you um
basically I started making YouTube
videos in 2012 I originally started
because I wanted to be a musician and
post my own awful self made music videos
which was just me standing in front of a
tripod singing which is why I call my
channel Emma blackery and then I started
reading Fifty Shades of Grey
online when it was released thinking hey
everyone's reading Twilight I'm gonna
read Fifty Shades of Grey and after they
nearly sued me for doing that video
copyright infringement and slacking off
the book I decided to start doing more
like comedy vlogs and stuff and that's
kind of taken over my channel now so
it's kind of like my channel is a
mixture of music slash comedy slash not
reading copyrighted well the funny thing
about reading copyrighted books is it's
only okay if you're slacking off on it
to use your phrase that I do not
actually know the meaning
oh yeah so that's that lesser that's
less a UK thing we have lots of slang
but slagging off basically just means
you're talking bad about it just okay I
believe you would say we just within for
British accent you know trash-talking
well it's like me saying it's like me
saying slagging Goff really stupid yeah
so but yeah I mean if you're if you're
actually critiquing the thing you are
reading then it's okay to read the
copyrighted material as long as you
don't read all of it in sequence which I
think then that is what you do what for
what if we shouldn't think that what I
think I think I probably could have
applied the fair use thing if I just
take in some things out of context and
read a few lines yes that would have
been fine but I'm a 70 minute long
videos just reading a chat just an
audiobook much of 50 shades of gray but
with occasional commentary about how bad
it is I'd pay for that so what about it
is a couple of weeks before mine got
taken down and they were like hey we
might sue you for this which they didn't
which was great another person who was
reading books online made a video saying
oh I had this book publishing company
take my videos down Derby books online
and I was like oh that's scary I better
stop now yeah it won't happen to me and
in two weeks later it has happened to me
so yeah
what Weiss if you want to start a
YouTube channel don't just don't read
copyright content well what was that uh
was that a contributor to your success
would you say it was it was that's how
my channel kind of started getting big
so thank you so yes thank you very much
in that case then the thing that you
should say is do do illegal uh things
that might get you sued but stop once
you get big which is really like that's
the whole story of how YouTube got big
YouTube used to just be like Family Guy
clips and Daily Show things Dolan yeah
it was all just TV shows before
copyright was even a thing like well
copyright was always a thing I mean like
Content ID and stuff where things just
get taken down now and audio gets taken
out you know I remember those days
oh that's like ten years ago now isn't
it
ten years ten year anniversary this
yeah and if I feel like if YouTube
hadn't had those days of just like being
a really great repository of stolen TV
stuff it would never have gotten as
popular as it did yeah I think you're
probably right on that because a lot of
people just wanted to access quick you
know quick clips and yeah cuz I mean the
first video was a guy at the zoo the
creator of YouTube wasn't it yes yeah
one of the cats yeah if it was just that
or people talking about a black and
white for 10 years I guess it wouldn't
have taken off no that's right you're
right
that's weird basically break the law
kids it's guys long yeah when as long as
you're small enough to get away with it
and then as soon as you're as soon as
he's starting to get on people's radar
run away and hide and then pretend like
that never happened and that's really
you know the story of many youtubers not
necessarily with copyrighted content but
with doing things that are slightly
maybe you know the little little devious
hacks and tweaks and dubious is a good
good word for it I like you yeah my word
of the week do I have one of the weeks I
never share with anybody I just say is
it really in a monologue sort of podcast
going on in my head a long time DBS is
my word of the week it's not even a joke
no I believe you yeah disbelief wasn't
it oh Jesus you're gonna have a lot of
opportunities to use the word dubious I
think today just because you're gonna
have a lot of opportunities to use a lot
of words cuz this is dear Hank and John
Oh what's Oh Emma and Hank this way
indeed yeah well I mean as long as if
that's the way you want to say it yeah
just wait until I can write a book and
promote it around the world and then I
worry available and then it just be dear
Hank and Hank oh no trouble oh god I'd
love to see that I would it be awful
nice if I could borrow wheezy waiters
cloning machine and do an episode of
dear Hank and Hank because uh you know
sometimes it's hard to get people on the
phone everybody's busy but I'm not when
I'm not busy I'm sorry there's a lot of
people that say oh you know there's
there's not you know one Emma blackery
is enough for one John Green is enough
but I genuinely think the world could do
with more Hank Green's honest friend
that sounds like I'm just you know
complimenting you and just trying to
make you blush but genuinely I think if
it was a world full of Hanks if
you were to replace every other living
being on this planet I think it would
probably be quite a fun place I get sick
I think I yeah I think it'd be super
boring it'd just been oh no things about
Mars all the time wouldn't it to be a
lot of things about Mars I think
probably uh III think that yeah well the
problem is that all the Hanks would want
to send humanity to Mars but none of
them would want to go because imagine
that which in hidden yeah the person's
quite a bit there just be a lot of
vomiting on the way you sure you
wouldn't go you sure
Oh one way ticket thing oh yeah
especially not with a one-way ticket I'm
not much on the risking of my own life
in any circumstance and Mars mission be
very dangerous one two I get motion sick
very easily and and so weightlessness is
sort of not not an option for me and
three I just I like like I live in
Montana like I if I wanted like a really
exciting high-stakes life I'd move to a
big city but I don't know like laid-back
I like normal things normal friends
normal life and doing the normal human
American things can I just say if you
want a life where you'll just climb in
big red rocks in really dry desert just
go to Utah oh yeah we got got some
pretty Mars like places I went to a
place called uh Bryce Canyon which I
didn't even know existed
oh it's beautiful yeah it was absolutely
gorgeous like I genuinely preferred it
to the Grand Canyon which a lot of
people were really shocked by but we had
a horseback ride down the canyon and it
was the scariest thing because twists
and turns were so sharp and these horses
didn't know what they were doing mine
was a mule so I mean it wasn't doing a
very good job of being a horse you know
um no but it was scary but it's so
beautiful there you know if you're into
the whole Red Rock kind of thing but
you're you're kind of afraid of space
travel and death by alien just just go
to Bryce Canyon just go to Utah there's
a little tiny town called Moab which was
absolutely beautiful oh my god no Eva's
not tiny town well no it's not but I
mean what we saw it was tiny okay okay I
don't I won't to the end of it and back
it was uh yeah okay it wasn't like it's
not like the tiniest town but it's
walkable
I live in Montana we're a tiny town has
like eight people oh okay well we don't
really have those kind of talents we
call them well we say that we say the
villages I guess but we don't really
have like really small towns anymore
yeah just not enough space for that in
your country well that's the thing
actually before we go on you'd be very
surprised because and if you've flown to
England before and you funny look down
and you the amount of green that we do
have in our country like yeah only
parity only ten percent of our like land
is inhabited seriously well that's a
hugely high percentage on the global
scale actually the specific figure but I
I know that it's a very small amount and
like our politicians I have you believe
oh there's no room for any more people
we should have any more immigrants come
in because we haven't got the room but
it's more cases the room yeah they
genuinely say that but the truth is
we're gonna put them exactly but the
truth is I guess we don't have the money
to build houses I guess that's what
they're trying to say right but they
know this sort of they build this vision
of like the island being so heavy that
it's six can't add any more people
exactly one more person and we're going
down boys we can't have it anymore
you know but I'm no I love it is just
it's just green you know yeah yeah you
got a you got a beautiful country it's
just uh it's just you know it's much
smaller and with far more people than uh
perper per unit of space yeah like it's
a lot more comfort
yeah it's that drinking squash rather
than just juice it's tough you don't
know what squash is do you I do not oh
cool do you had a cordial nope that's
unfamiliar as well it's like really
really concentrated juice that you water
down oh we call that concentrate oh well
we we don't call it concentrate you get
a whole take only word for it whole
podcast is just me translate well you
translating what I'm saying well you
translating what you're saying uh to you
yeah to many thing what does this mean
I don't know you're spelling me oh well
thank you for educating me do you want
to hear some questions yeah that's
that's kind of why I'm here
just talking about my own country jeez
yes send me some questions all right our
first question is from Alpha who asks
dear Hank and Emma
this is mostly for Emma last year I
started a channel for music but I've
been inactive for about a year now and
now I'm willing to come back but I can't
find the motivation Emma inspired me a
lot these past few days as she's been
watching your videos and I want to know
what keeps her inspired in making music
videos and writing music
I need your sage advice okay what keeps
you inspired confused she said in the
last few days I think I haven't done the
thing in the last few days I sort of sat
in bed feeling really tired
that's how inspiring at all I cut a bit
out of the question where she talked
about how she's been binge watching your
videos okay good good I was gonna say
like spying on me just eating crisps in
my underwear or so chips potato chips Oh
to me okay um terms of keeping inspired
I mean in terms of videos I get
inspiration from anywhere like just
today I was I was in a store and I
bought a shirt and the the lady said ah
that's a nice shirt and easily I thought
I'm gonna make a video about this when I
sit when when store assistants judged
the clothes you're buying you know like
I get inspiration for that sort of thing
just everyday stuff that noise don't do
that
why not don't gel don't like tell me
whether you like the clothes I'm buying
or not because that means there are some
clothes in the store that you don't like
and what if I pick that up and you're
too rude to say what if I really like
this shirt what if you're saying that
because the last thing that you veep's
roof for my stuff was really horrible
you know what I like though I really
like when I'm like at an ice cream shop
or or some food place where you sort of
create your own item yeah and and I like
I'm gonna get a root beer float but
instead of vanilla I'm gonna use
cardamom ice cream and then the person
behind the counter is like ooh that
sounds so good it makes me feel like
this person is like they work at an ice
cream shop there at connoisseur they've
heard everything but I like the idea
that I could impress them with my my
superior ice cream ordering skills
that's true um in the UK I don't know if
you guys have this um but we have it
where you go into a restaurant and you
say like what would you recommend yeah
you ask the waitress like what would you
recommend or server whatever you guys
say but like I find that really weird
because you're saying to someone else
with completely different
Budds completely different genetics like
what what food pleases your palate it's
like I mean everyone is different well
but this this is a person who is a has
more expertise than you do they work at
the restaurant they've seen the things
prepared they've theoretically tried a
lot of the different dishes I totally
get that but I just find that really
weird because what if it's someone
because I've had it before they say oh
well I really like this and it's topped
with almonds and nuts and I'm just like
well I hate nuts yeah well yes I also
oftentimes it'll be like the muscles are
particularly great here and I'm like
that sounds disgusting
exactly do not talk to me and throw them
away for you how's that horrible anyway
in terms of being inspired yeah making
videos it I think actually kind of sadly
it's more a case of it's all I got right
now like I quit my job to start doing
this like I was I was a waitress and I
stayed on in more money from YouTube
than I did from which thing and I was
like hey you know what I'm gonna try
real hard to make a living out of this
and I was able to but if I stop making
videos then I guess I go back to
waitressing you know when I get up at 6
o'clock 6 o'clock in the morning again
this is a case of I have to do it which
sounds like a really bad sort of
inspiration it kind of makes you sad
that you gonna hate it like it's job now
um and I think that's very very good in
keeping me inspired it's like well if I
don't do it I'm poor um in terms of
music I I'm a really bad role model in
terms of inspiring people to make music
because I haven't written anything in
about a year so so I this the thing
because a lot of people are saying this
day actually someone else um some people
write music every day but they're a
musician should just pick up a guitar
write a new song every single day they
force themselves to get inspired I can't
do that like I I genuinely when I go
with my writing process is okay I've got
an EP that I need to write in about two
weeks I'm gonna be recording in two
weeks I better write some songs and I'll
just I'll just work on four or five
songs you know and luckily they've all
turned out pretty alright I think um but
it you know I I don't really I don't
force myself to write I if it sounds
like you do force yourself to write it
sounds like you yeah but not like like
every record of me pees right right
yeah like having those like having that
that thing that you have to get done Oh
for me that's a lot of what it is - it's
like you know from the beginning of
vlogbrothers we've had a schedule that
we have to abide by or else Tom and
knowing that knowing that I have to have
a video done every Friday means that I'm
thinking you know certainly today and
and also all of the previous days of the
week like what the heck is that video
going to be about is it going to be a
response to John is it going to be
something about how to make sure that
you don't use like I've been seeing a
lot of people like friends emailing me
and like they use the wrong word and I'm
just like that's fine I know what word
you mean I'm not gonna like correct you
on it but if I were like an employer I'd
be like that you can't you got to watch
you got to not do that uh-huh you got it
yeah so maybe make a video about like
here's some words that people commonly
use wrong and this will prevent you from
looking like an idiot not that you are
an idiot but you don't want to look like
one
so she's inspiration from like everyday
thanks you get a script but like but
it's not like the thing that's really
inspiring isn't the everyday thing it's
the knowing that you have to make a
thing and so you're constantly your
brain is on looking for things to make
things with exactly like if your creates
witches on you can find inspiration from
a lot of places I think in a way I want
to say you're kind of lucky in the UC
obviously you and John started this
channel is simply you know vlogbrothers
to talk to each other so it's a case of
if you wanted to quit at any time you
kind of could but you kept it up because
you you would dedicate to it both of you
and then suddenly you amass this massive
community of people the nerdfighters
that suddenly were also depending on
these videos so it's not just your
brother that wants a video every Friday
it's like three million people and in
the end that's the most inspiring thing
is like the that the knowing that I
can't let these people down but that's
not helpful to somebody who doesn't
already have an audience but like that's
really the thing that keeps me making
videos and keeps me like caring a lot
about whether or not they're good and
like reading when I know that they're
not what they could be is that
I have these people who I rely on and
have given me great gifts and I can't
let them down
true like sometimes I I look at all the
things you're involved with and I just
think how is he doing this have you
actually got wheezy waiters cloning
machine because now instead of a cloning
machine I hire people which which is how
I do it still you it's still you with
crash course and scishow and
vlogbrothers and I see you all over the
place now you've got a podcast I I can't
come up with you there must be six of
you masturbate I I sleep a normal amount
I work more than an average person but
only because my work is so fun and yeah
I just have lots of help and lots of and
I also have that like and also an
inspiring thing about having this
audience is that they they are like
because they're passionate and they want
to help and like we share values if I
have a new idea a new thing they're
likely to come and check it out and at
least see if they like it and if they
don't they might go away but if they do
they might become new loyal podcast
listeners and and and sometimes just the
fact that you can do something it feels
like you could since you can you should
and you kind of have an obligation to
because especially if other people want
to do that thing and and and like you
have an easy path to it and I sometimes
feel like a jerk if I'm like well I
could but like I don't have time yeah to
fulfill this thing that is that a dream
of millions of people like the problem
either is that I often get really
spontaneous I'll go through phases where
like I'm gonna make this channel this is
genius idea I'm gonna make dedicate to
do it and they're like a month later I
would just be like I haven't uploaded on
there for three weeks you know I'm
really awful it just making really rash
decisions like I don't plan things out I
just do them which I am working on it's
it's all about self-improvement yeah you
got to be a better human every day
that's kind of one of my sayings but
yeah I was I was get really excited
about projects I'm like yeah I'm gonna
film I like when I am when I came up my
second channel which is like a lifestyle
Beauty kind of thing I film like 20
videos in advance I was like save now
now I'm ahead now I can keep doing this
now I haven't uploaded in there in about
three weeks so because it's like be
inspired is hard I think yeah I think
it's hard to keep yourself motivated but
um I would say at first I don't know
because I don't know if it's better to
apply pressure to yourself as in you
know you have to have this done like you
and John do or whether it's easier to
not play fresh in yourself and go I'm
going to take it slow I'm going to do it
my own pace which is kinda what I do but
I think it's it depends on what works
for you really I mean I think we we both
work in very different ways but right
you know we both get our content up yeah
that's true I mean I think that the for
me forcing yourself to do something even
if nobody's watching is great because I
think no matter what if you're creating
you're improving yourself you're like
you're you're being empathetic you're
thinking about what other people think
would think about your content you're
creating stuff that you think is good
you're getting better at creating you're
getting better at thinking critically
like all that stuff is is part of the
making process no matter what you're
making if you're making a business or a
painting or a video blog it's it's all
about like these are very it's a very
complicated exercise and no matter
whether you know you're doing it just
for yourself
or you're doing it for an audience it's
always a kind of self-improvement so I
try to think of it that way even when
I'm making something that I know that
somebody's never going to see I'm like
well at least I'm doing this thing that
that's helping me understand myself
better and helping me understand the
world better yeah like I think no matter
what it is no matter who sees it if it
has a positive outcome whether it's for
you or whether it's just for like you
and a friend or like you know if no
one's going to see it and it just makes
you feel better then do it if it's only
got a positive thing then no there's no
reason why you shouldn't do it and
there's I mean it's almost like because
there's now this this in this very sort
of terrifying internet thing where
anybody's creation if it's clever funny
enough can get you know a million notes
on tumblr that it's almost not worth it
to make something that's not gonna get a
million notes on tumblr but that's of
course a fallacy I think I think it's a
trap that a lot of YouTube is going to
like a lot of YouTube is fooling so I
mean iPhone lives in strap where you
think I'm gonna make this video because
it's going to go viral and it
worst way of thinking is completely
completely poisonous when you you choose
a topic you think oh that's that's going
to get a lot of views because that's the
worst thing you can do because it
especially if you've started to build an
audience through not doing that
like what most wheezywaiter even me like
I just I've just talking to a camera
about my own personal view so when you
start making videos that you think oh
that's kind of a clickbait title that's
the sort of thing that buzz for you
would do you know which is what I've
kind of done recently admittedly you
know it's it's good for views but it's
not good for the audience that you
already have and they really like you're
abandoning them so to stay true to
yourself and at the end a I would say in
terms of you know inspire it being
inspired to make music and videos just
make them for yourself
and I always say that make videos you
would enjoy watching and eventually the
people that enjoy your stuff will find
you
you know if YouTube works yeah as long
as as long as all the parts don't break
do you want to do you want to give us
another question sure I'll read the next
one this one is from Ellen and she says
I'm in America with school for the first
time I'm from the UK and I tried a corn
dog for the first time yesterday and I
understand now why you like them so much
Hank I'm not really sure if John likes
them too I just want to ask if you could
only ever eat one food again what would
it be my answer is definitely not corn
dogs I think they're the worst thing on
the planet
you've had a corn dog that's a
controversial I have yeah I had one at
Disney it was a it was literally a hot
dog fried just deep-fried in batter yes
so we're saying it it didn't work I just
thought it was awful I cannot understand
how you feel the way you feel
I understand how what I mean is I
understand how people can like them
because they've got that kind of
satisfying crunch the texture but for me
it was just I'd maybe it was the way
it's cooked
maybe it wasn't done right at Disney but
it was really greasy and I was just
sitting he made me feel really full
although I had eaten an entire dill
pickle before because it's much that I
like corn dogs I can just eat a whole
dill pickle you guys do them in bags we
don't have that in a matter in the UK
you guys do like bagged pickles it's the
best thing
they take the neck out of you know they
make fun of them Canadians having bad
meat bag milk but guys have bad pickles
and I think that's the best invention um
since I've only ever eat one food again
it would probably be bad pickles dill
pickle I think like great I've done a C
on that that sounds so awful to me
that's my you don't like pickles I don't
like pickles there's so there's way too
much flavor in a pickle
all the vinegar it's painful it's just
it is clearly a chemical that is
designed to kill things which is what
pickling is and and so I don't I don't
know why one would pour a bunch of you
know dilute acetic acid solution into
their stomachs I only found out like
about a year ago with a pickle is just a
cucumber like I only found that out
about a year ago it's just a cucumber
vinegar and it blew my mind
I thought pickles just grew yeah I'm I'm
awful will they give a different name
and everything they do you name it
because you've shoved it in acid well
it's not okay I might get that framed
don't rename it cuz you've shoved it in
acid it's strange that uh that there's
lots of pickled things like you can have
pickled beets and you can have onion
it's great pickled onions and and and
pickled like relishes is a kind of
pickled like pickled things
yeah and relish but you can't have you
can't have pickled cucumbers you just
have pickles exactly
it's Jam it and what if you had a pickle
so it's a pickle cucumber and then you
put it back in vinegar cuz then it's
just a pickle pickle and that doesn't
make any sense it doesn't make sense it
can you pick up a pickle a pickle base
the picker was a verb you can't do that
you know changing the verb to a noun
that's not right English like I was mad
but I liked them I think they're great I
don't know how often you personally eat
McDonald's but I have to ask you're the
kind of guy that would take the pickle
out of the Big Mac yeah yeah well my
wife loves pickles so I take the pickle
out of the big back and I give them to
her and she like it's double pickles
good cuz like even though I don't eat
Big Macs in law because I recently went
vegetarian we should explain why I don't
like corn dogs
I'm the person well I used to be the
person everyone would just you know
they'd take out the pickle and just
throw it at me well though we call them
the gherkins over here so that's a good
name see that's better
GHG rkin gokhan and can you can you
explain to me what a haitch is no H you
owe us a H do you mean H correct oh do
you know what really annoys me and a lot
of British people why don't you say hub
it's a H it has a H it's a hub it's not
an herb
what's an herb it's vegan with a u I
just I'm just really enjoying you saying
herb it's awful I'm uh I'm using you as
the spokesperson for America right now
why do you say
why do you say why do you say an herb
yeah that's true and because that's just
awful like that makes no sense the only
reason that the N exists do so is you do
thing well I know I've heard British
people say that my I will have to check
so that we can cut this part of the
podcast if I'm wrong but I'm pretty sure
I'm right well I mean in my accent I'm
from a place called Essex which is
notorious for having sort of you know
like cockney rhyming slang and the sort
of commoners like Oliver Twist please
sir can I have some more I know it's
like London but imagine those old-time
Londoners coming to another place that's
what Essex is and that's what my accent
is like Russell Brand and it's that
accent and we would say have you got any
herbs like would you say herbs but we
say if you got any herbs not like herbs
you know and we leave our juice with my
accent and now are not convincing me
that that's different because of course
you say it differently because you have
an accent but you don't use the you hurt
either
so hops we everyone has an accent all
right
happy July rules you came it when we are
not taught that history you know that
right I never learned anything to do
Independence Day in history oh I'm so
sorry I guess you guys still feel bad
about it you're like ashamed of losing a
war
this pretty much today we're all
Americans really loud and the British
just go really really quiet
really quiet we've totally you know like
that's so separate like the July 4th is
so separate from the idea of
independence from the UK we never think
of independence from Britain we think of
independence just like we are
independent we are free then mostly
we're thinking about mostly this thing
about ourselves and and in no way do we
consider America's context at the
broader context of America in in global
society
in fact joy forth is the day on which
you want to do that the least because if
you do that then it get kind of
complicated and you're like is America
great it's a lot of good and bad things
but you don't want to feel that way you
want to be like boom that thing exploded
give me a hot dog exactly I mean other
way to get in a war of whatever the t
thing was about and then you got the
smallpox thing I said we're not doing
any of it so yeah it's just no that's
fine
you got you well we're not taught
anything about all of your wonderful
kings and in your and you're Cromwell's
and you know we don't know anything
about that skip over World War one well
kind of comes up and not that it comes
up when you're like 13 14 it's like no
people die at the end
Hitler it was bad yeah World War 1 bad
idea don't do that again okay uh or just
do it again immediately yeah either way
years later guy who served in one yeah
patís yeah
yep all right we're we're good at we're
good at chatting we're good at chatting
I haven't answered the question I would
probably eat I don't know what would I
eat I and I'm probably not know I think
I like I would have to I would want
something that would have enough
nutritional content for me to not die of
a vitamin deficiency if it was a single
piece of food and you wanted to live
forever I would probably recommend a
tomato ooh I don't like them I mean I
like them leave this podcast I know I
like them I just I couldn't eat them
like by myself by themselves every day
by themselves as a snack hold it all
right Sarah asks dear Hank and John I'm
in my first year of med school and I
failed chemistry which means that I have
to do it next year
we'll delay my career I have always been
a good student so this is the worst
thing that has ever happened to me and I
feel like a complete failure do you have
any tips on dealing with screwing up
yeah it's happened now so yeah it's like
didn't that's it like you can't go back
and I hate when people say like you know
if you could do things differently what
would you do and then they say oh well I
wouldn't do anything differently because
it's meant to be this way because even
though I believe in fate and I honestly
do believe everything he's meant to
happen for a reason
which you may disagree with being a
scientific kinda guy but I think when it
comes to screwed up you have to say to
yourself at the time I did my best and
it didn't go the way I planned and now
instead of dwelling on the past I have
to find a way of working around it if
it's put you behind a year that year is
going to give you a lot more experience
in life and you might even just you
might have some life-changing things
happen in the next year you know and you
might find that you you're actually a
lot more well equipped to do the next
year yeah in the year that it's taking
you to get back on the track but I think
that comes to if you wake up if you wake
up every day and feel bad about every
mistake you've made
you're just not one of yous not gonna
want to get out of bed and I think
that's a very bad way of living if you
just live in regret all the time
completely agree I actually majored in
chemistry in the first my first semester
of chemistry I did very poorly I don't I
think I got a C it wasn't bad enough
that I had to retake the class but it
was bad enough that I was like I have I
did not expect to yeah I did not expect
to ever do this poorly in a class like I
thought that I always would always do
well because I'd always done well in
high school because High School's pretty
easy and and what I did for the next
that you know like what I did was I was
like well I can't I can't do the same
thing I did again I have to I have to
think about this differently and so it
was an opportunity to say like what like
why didn't I learn this well why didn't
why wasn't I able to do this and like
clicks I kind of completely reformed the
way I studied and tried to learn things
and like I thought about it carefully
not about like chemistry but about how I
learned
and something it may be a case of things
just not sticking in your brain properly
or that you you didn't understand a
certain formula you like you never kind
of got it and the nerves got the better
of you or something but you go if you go
back not just relearning that subject
that you didn't do well at but the way
that you process things I think you're
completely right I think that's one of
the best things you can do yourself
personally and one of the glaring how to
learn is is really the trick of school
ah definitely I wish I knew that ten
years ago yes actually revised anything
ten years ago I didn't study at all I
never studied I was the arrogant kid who
never did any homework
never never did any studying and still
got AIDS except this one time I was in
what you guys would call middle school I
was 15 I think that's middle school I
think maybe the shirt oh uh we just call
it a secondary school but um I just I
started studying physics it was a
subject you could take at middle school
and in the first lesson he our teacher
made us take a pop quiz and I went in
there thinking yeah I've done really
well in science so far I've got this I
like physics physics he's cool and I got
an e which was the lowest you could get
because he refuses I remember just
getting it back like the next lesson and
I just I stayed behind after class and
cried my eyes out because it was such a
slap in the face not like not in a
fended way but it was like reality hit
me hard that I'm clearly not good at
this as I thought oh I thought I would
just waltz in there and do well and come
out going yeah that was easy but I I sat
behind with my teacher I said you know
I'm really upset what did I do wrong and
he was like first off you need to just
you need to calm down crying is not
gonna give you a name and that kind of
that advice just sort of brought me
through the next year I worked super
hard I actually did the homework for
that class that I was lucky because my
teacher actually made it interesting and
you really really enjoyed studying
physics with him I'm all those really
really really easy physics no we didn't
even learn many formulas or anything it
was just a Chernobyl mostly for the
whole um but I'm at the end of it and
when I took GCC's I don't know what you
guys
call them your end of middle school
exams I had gone a in physics so I went
having an e and then oh I got an a star
which is this is like a plus hmm
so I got like the highest Marquis yet
because I applied myself and I had a
teacher who was really supportive so I
would also say like if you feel as
though you've let yourself down in terms
of chemistry go back to your tutor and
just have a chat with them and say I
feel really knocked back my confidence
is completely gone
you know what can I do and see if they
can give you extra classes
I don't know obviously how the American
school system works but if there's a way
of like staying behind and you know
having revision sessions you know
studying then I'd be able for that as
well yeah absolutely I talk a lot
wow you can really go wow geez yeah
sorry I feel like you I feel like you've
kind of remembered a great deal about
your your childhood there uh that maybe
you haven't thought about it no yeah it
was like eight years ago
yeah like he was he was a good teacher
but um yeah I think that this is funny
gonna be the longest podcast ever have
fun editing yeah indeed Cat Cat asks
dear Hank and oh what what what okay
fine and you missed a question oh you're
right I did which is really important so
you won't reading the right question but
you skipped me oh right right is it like
being a dog brother huh um Andrew asks
dear Hank and Emma or dear ever and Hank
if Eugene something sermon Curtis Onan
you know who that is
I don't um if that dude had left a bacon
sandwich on the moon in 1971 number one
with the bacon sandwich still be safe
enough to eat and number two given the
chance would interview each said bacon
sandwich I don't know about the first
one but second one was kind of easy I'm
vegetarian so no unless it was corn
bacon in which case I think life is too
short to not eat a moon sandwich
I would say if a national counting went
hey we found this in the moon you want
to eat it you'd be an idiot to say no
all right III will I will venture a
guess on number one which is that it
would still be safe to eat yeah yeah
oxygen in space just look like not just
tiny tiny bit ah yeah I I think that
four years
it's been a long time uh but what the
question really isn't it has it degraded
or oxidized which would not make it
unsafe it would just make it less tasty
which it definitely would be less tasty
he wouldn't make it unsafe though
because it even if it had bacteria on it
would probably be sterilized by that the
temperature fluctuations it would be
very hot and then very cold because like
the sides of the moon one faces the Sun
it like you know it'll get ya oh yeah
the surface of the Moon gets gets hot
because it's in the Sun that's fine and
and then and it would be sort of but it
would be bombarded by the Rays of the
Sun which would also sterilize it so it
would be safe to eat I'm pretty sure and
and unless I'm missing some way that
bacon could decay into something
dangerous oh yeah
oh but like it's like there's a bunch of
yeah you see well yeah so what would
happen is like the high-energy UV
radiation of the Sun would would
sterilize and break down the sandwich
like that like if you if just like sort
of a bacon sandwich sitting sitting in
space the thing that would eventually
degrade it would just be being bombarded
by the radiation like solar radiation
tiny new asteroids that actually would
be a thing like it eventually it would
probably be hit by enough tiny little
asteroids that it would break apart uh
that is a good point
imagine a sandwich floating in space and
that's time the rock just hitting it
like they can flying out in slow motion
yeah that's that's a beautiful beautiful
image space worked ever late would your
sandwich even move would it break apart
how did you see the move in space
there's no there's nothing up there I
mean it's also completely dark how would
you see if anything that you know well
if it's not rest with the bacon sandwich
booth knows I should be on scishow right
I wouldn't be given answers I'm just
doing hypothetical questions and then
bug myself out like this we if you want
to just send us scishow questions for us
to answer and it like to have an Emma
blackery segment of like how did things
even move in space I don't understand
how space works then I would be happy to
answer those questions like being a
president of space so I could get a
question I don't know what the question
was but now that this is a now this is
official there is definitely going to be
an Emma blackery segment on every
scishow it's confirmed by anchoring
himself alright it's done uh and given
the chance would I eat the bacon
sandwich
I would first want to do science on the
bacon sandwich I don't know what kind of
science I'd want to do but time for
science give a bacon sandwich I mean if
you're gonna bring it back to earth it
started to get degrade they can start to
warm up since he got back in the rocket
ship rocket ship spaceship I don't know
I just watch kids TV you know it's gonna
start degrading it's gonna start getting
gross you have to eat pretty quick I did
food hygiene courses when I was a
waitress and you've only got a few hours
before that meat gets nasty so alright
you don't have to probe it unless you're
gonna like freeze it with that maybe
I'll eat half the bacon sandwich and
leave the other half to do to do science
I'd yeah but I think if given the
opportunity you have to eat a space
sandwich thank you
it's a moon sandwich thank you okay even
if Austin the next question all right
cat asks dear Hank and Emma how are you
feeling about Google Google+ these days
ah
they they they we want on a date and
they didn't they didn't come back they I
think they swiped left or something I
don't know um Google+ don't hate me
which is good really yeah they don't and
they hate me for a while apparently I
was actually told by a few people who
knew people who worked at Google that
they really really were mad at me
Jane if people don't know what's going
on Emma wrote a song about how how she
did not it feel enthusiastic about the
transition of YouTube's
sign-in system to integrate with Google+
which is a Google social media and
so they were kind of mad for a few weeks
after I wrote that song and about a week
after I released it I had to go into
Google for a meeting which it was all
right I thought would be really awkward
but they just didn't mention it which
apparently now I have actually heard
that a lot of people who work within
Google Plus said they completely agree
with the song which is quite bad I think
if you work for a social media site and
they go yes she was right our sites
awful I'm not gonna name names but yeah
a few people have said to me yeah they
they actually like it and they realize
you were right and now no one's a
Google+ and I'm not saying I brought
down an entire social media web site by
myself but you know it did go viral
you're looking at the person that can
bring down a social web site whether
you've lady well we're not looking at
you but we are listening to you here on
dear Hank and John podcast that is
brought to that brought to you by
Google+ oh right now the song about how
great they are
I can go and find a ukuleles you should
do that you should you should come back
and you should write a song about how
wonderful Google+ is and how wrong you
were
on April 1st saying we love you
Google+ they just oh yeah they just over
dumped it with her it's the best thing
since sliced bread and it was terrible
and how are you feeling about Google+ oh
you know the usual
wait yeah times you know okay I don't I
don't think about Google+ ever I don't
think it thinks about you Hank but I
don't think it thinks let's hope it
doesn't think cuz if it's got Google+ go
sentian I am running for my life
seriously
yes hide like a transformer I am running
away he will not find me I would be on
the moon I know he knows I'll be in the
moon he's listening can I ask you a
question at Walmart is it sure they sell
guns in Walmart
wait yes that is true that's ridiculous
that's like my local supermarket that's
that's like as they're selling guns
what yep you have a yup gun section is
that thing it's like a it's like in the
fishing Rob section
no-no-no so like you got that you got
like where that where the word like the
fishing supplies and the camping
supplies are then there's also guns so
that you can take didn't shoot a deer or
something but I mean like they don't let
you just pick up a gun fire nope like
you have shooting Rangers in the in the
US and everything but you can just take
your gun take your neighbourhood gun you
know well it's not like a shared gun
it's your own gun you take your gun down
you could take it to the shooting range
in and practice your your gunman ship
yeah guys I also think it's weird it is
not like I am a gun owner myself I do
not know I don't I mean kids get [ __ ]
shot I mean it's not it's not worth it
it's not worth the second slash whatever
amendment you guys well I mean for a lot
of people it is the Second Amendment yes
freedom of speech right correct that's
all I know
yeah so we have the freedom of we have a
freedom of speaking with your mouth and
you also have the freedom of being able
to if the circumstance of rise to speak
with your guns
yeah oh this next question is good you
want to read out sure uh Holly asks your
Hank and Emma I'm a senior in high
school and I'm very very short luckily
for me I'm a girl and girls don't get
teased as often about being short as
guys do and also high heels exist but
I'm also not very good about feeling
confident about my shortness and I was
wondering if you have any advice my
advice as someone who is a hundred and
150 seven centimeters which is not tall
it's five foot two
my advice would be you can't do anything
about it you're stuck you're not going
to grow so you either hate yourself the
rest of life or you embrace it and for
instance I I used to I was never teased
for being short I had people I always
have people use it as an icebreaker
whenever I meet people who watch my
videos I say you're so short in real
life as if I don't know
yeah and I've actually taken to it
sometimes I've been really sarcastic and
just jump back and go oh my god really
ah oh my god it was so tall and just
freaking out you know sarcastic ways
just to make them feel really good about
it
but now I'm just like well you know
people were just gonna try and use an
icebreaker pen terms like being teased I
was never I was I was never teased about
it um but I I started seeing it in a
positive light for instance if you're
sure you are the last person to know
when it's raining and you are the last
person that's going to get really
drenched in in heavy rain and if you
were to climb Mount Everest at exactly
the same time as a tool person you would
live longer because the air will be
thinner back the other people um there
you would be the first to probably die
in a room that was flooding if you
couldn't get out but I try to not think
of that one but you know I mean being
short has it has its benefits oh sure
like I can I can walk under many low
bridges that my friends have to duck
under I don't have to duck I hardly ever
have to duck you know which is great um
if I fall over it's not as far to the
ground so so it even though you'd think
it would be proportional
it doesn't hurt much I'm sure of it now
that is definitely true um III would say
as a tall person so I'm 6:1 which is
above average uh I never notice how like
the height of other people unless they
are taller than me so because 90% of
people are shorter than me
I like all people who are shorter than
me are the same height too in my
perception so just as like to understand
how people who are taller than you are
seeing it they're probably not seeing
you as particularly short just yeah I
really and well I guess like when
somebody gets to be like like 5 foot 4
411 kind of height then I'm liking what
you are a short person and like I see
that but like I never feel like it's a
fit - that's even sure I am very small I
think 5 oh you mean like 4 foot 11
yes I know inside foot okay you meant
like 5 foot 4 and 11 bits of an inch or
something like that's really specific
fair enough yeah like you can best think
you notice like the extremities like for
instance I wouldn't got to you I
wouldn't think wow hangri
is really tall because you do see people
who are six foot one yes I'm not saying
you're very very common I'm just saying
that you know you say yes it isn't about
you know it's above average height but
it's not it's not like ridiculously tall
like I know people who are six or seven
and they are very very tall yeah then
it's been it's like what just happened
like if you see Rhett of rhett and Link
then then you're like oh my goodness and
then he's got the hair yeah you'll yeah
you'll come you come up to his his waist
he's ridiculous why I find very annoying
is that I I once had a friend who like
there was like six foot six and we went
on tour together and people just made us
stand next to each other all the time
just because it's funny I was genuinely
nipple height um it was horrible I
really really was nipple height but
another good thing about being short is
that if you are a kind generous person
if you are quite sure if you're five
foot two you are the absolute perfect
height for an armrest
if someone tall or of an average height
is standing next to you and they want to
ponder they wanted to sink you know
stroke their beard but have their arm
resting on something you are the best
perch your shoulder is an incredible
perch I make people do it when they need
to think when they're stressed out say
perch perch over here and just happen my
shoulder and they do and I feel better
so you know it's all about embracing the
things that you don't like about
yourself I mean if you're really really
really insecure about things that you
can change then I am all for people
changing them I'm completely pro plastic
surgery if the reasons are good if the
reasons are just because it makes you
feel more comfortable with with with
your height there's not much you can do
apart from laser wear high heels or that
really drastic surgery don't if you
heard about it wearing yeah yeah you
like break your legs and ya know regrow
the bone and you gain about two inches
um and I've I've read stories about
people who've done that they say they
don't regret it even though he looks
like a year of your life but I would say
honestly quite frankly you can't do
anything about it you're sure yeah you
know well and the other thing about
being short is that it's a it's it's bit
fine like I don't know that anybody has
a lot of negative like they're a sort of
a general negative series of opinions
about short especially short women
connotations yeah shoot men you kind of
see him as like Lord Farquaad from Shrek
a little bit sometimes yeah you think
should people man like plankton from
Sponge Bob you know you
Oh is a Shou evil person with women a
lot of people just see it cute is cute
which is actually very very sexist but
totally oh yes definitely but I yeah and
it this is a problem with society not
with the people who have who are you
know at the outskirts of a bell curve
and this yeah so the good news is it's
not that bad of a thing to be in terms
of society's weird Hang Ups not in terms
of like reality which of course it's not
in terms of reality but and the the
other good news is that even if it were
something that is is like society is
weird and hung up about the the best
thing you can be is confident about yeah
it in in your in your knowledge that
society is weird about things that are
even the very slightest bit different
and that that has nothing to do with you
and everything to do with how weird our
like in general cultures can be you
can't change culture immediately or on
your own but but just you know being
being comfortable and and like I know so
many strong powerful amazing short women
and it turns out that it has nothing to
do with with anything about them except
for how how high up they can reach yeah
basically the shortly you are the better
you are is what I was trying to say so
if I'm a poor one listen to if you're a
five-foot-four Hank is not going to like
you but I mean you won't you're
completely right like you know your
height doesn't reflect anything about
your pop and how you feel about your
height that's the only thing it reflects
people I mean I would say the final
thought to to to Hallie
if that's how you pronounce it might be
Haley maybe Hallie I don't know I'm
English
I would say how often how many hours a
day do you spend looking at people going
wow they're tall well they're short Wow
they're average those people probably
spending the same amount of time as you
not not not at all you know it's very
easy to overthink it especially if
you're really insecure about it like I
used to be really secure about my teeth
to think everyone was costly stone at my
teeth the fact is when someone's talking
they're looking about lip-read you know
but you you do get very self-conscious
but it's about overcoming it and
embracing it I'm totally fine with being
short now I mean you may hell you might
be shorter than me but it's a case of
you have to find the positives in it
otherwise it's just going to completely
weigh you down or get your legs broken
your choice those are their options
we have one last question I think and
it's from me apparently how many is it
and says it's a girl called Emma I wrote
this I I wrote this question
no I didn't I says like it would be
really really weird if I sent this
question in a few weeks ago thinking oh
I love this I love this podcast I hope
John answers my question but that would
be bad first time I shall she read this
so Emma dear Hank and Emma I know
there's people we're always growing and
changing I'm someone who believes
everything happens for a reason
I'm completely sane however some of the
things that we do are just absolutely
cringy and horrible so my question is
how do you not regret the bad or strange
things you've done even knowing it made
you who you are that's a good question
you just you already answered this
question this podcast date yeah you do
you regret them you regret the bad and
strange things you've done and part and
part of that regret is what made you who
you are
yeah I regret and don't regret your
regret because then you just get caught
up in the cycle well the thing is like
when you hear that day in day out but
you still get really like cringy about
the things you've done it doesn't really
it does really help when someone says oh
well it's made you who you are today
because that doesn't negate the fact
that great you did really embarrassing I
think it's completely I think it's a
very very very positive thing to regret
something because it means you've grown
it means you've changed it means that
you going back in time you wouldn't do
that thing therefore you are a better
person as I said earlier in the podcast
my main motto in life is to be a better
person every day improve on yourself
every single day and looking back at
things you've done thinking oh why did I
do that that means that you wouldn't
make those mistakes again and it's good
because if you if you said to yourself
oh I don't regret anything I've done
then in a way you're almost being
foolish in a way that you're thinking oh
well it was meant to be that way you
know and you'll leave the door open to
thinking that you might do it again
you know like with my music and
I don't want to keep you know I'm not
trying to promote our music which you
can buy in iTunes is this podcast is
sponsored by my EPS
but I would I look back at my old music
and some of the songs I'm like oh that
song is so boring or that song is so
simple it was like the first thing that
I have released on on YouTube I love the
song at the time I thought we were so
catchy but now listen to it I was like
oh this is so awful the lyrics are so
bad but I don't see that's a bad thing
I see the song as bad but I see it as
good that I'm now looking at it as an
improved person saying that clearly I
have got better at writing if I find
this bad yeah I mean regret serves a
purpose in us in it it's a thing that is
unpleasant but it triggers the analysis
of our previous actions that led to
negative outcomes and that analysis is
good up to a point you know over
analyzing that getting caught up into it
and and and never leaving it behind is
as it is you know a kind of disorder but
you know in general regret and and
considering and like those those like
cringy feelings of like oh god I did
that thing it it's about giving you an
opportunity to think about you know the
actions you have taken that have led to
negative outcomes and why they led to
those negative outcomes so don't get
caught up too much in regretting things
but don't not regret them the thing that
you that that like I really disliked in
our culture is often this idea that like
you can't you know you have to stay true
to your something and to me you know the
self like Who I am is a different person
every day like I'd like we constantly
evolve we create ourselves and we're
different from day to day and that is
not something to be ashamed of it's
something to be proud of because that
means that you know like ideally you're
you you have more life experience you
have a better understanding of yourself
and other people and that's allowing you
to grow as a person which means that
you're going to look back at some of the
things you've done and said and be like
oh why was why why did I believe that
or why did I make that stupid mistake or
why did I give into that that base
emotion and do that mean thing and
that's good because it means that like
hopefully in the next the next time
you're faced with you know like giving
into a base emotion and doing a mean
thing you'll be like well I don't want
to feel this this bad this regret that I
felt for years about that time that I
did a thing like that so I shouldn't do
it this time
it's good like if you order chili cheese
for us and you didn't like them it's
okay to regret it because then you're
not going to all them again is what ank
is basically saying I just Jess in the
analogy of chili cheese fries which I
don't like
oh yeah except the problem with your the
problem with your analogy is that chili
cheese fries are amazing oh you like
everything I hate I would just have I
would just have the dill pickles I'm
fine uh-huh oh how hard but I mean I
would have to say really really quickly
before we move on to the news of this
week's podcast oh no Bob if its weekly
or monthly or what by now I would also
just really quickly say that even though
I say you know you should you know you
it's okay to regret things don't live in
that regret like you said I think it is
important to be able to you know keep
the past separate from who you are now
like let your past experience affect who
you are today in a way that means you
know you won't do that bad thing again
but don't just don't don't dwell on them
too much you know I mean I know that's
something I said I don't like it when
people say that I completely agree vemma
that I I personally do believe in fate I
believe in destiny I do believe that
everything is planned out I believe it's
all mapped out for you and I understand
that might not be something that a lot
of you would you know agree with but
that's that's the belief that I have and
it keeps me going I try not to preach
about it but um but if it's it's a case
of you have to be able to say that was
then and this is now it's it's gonna
keep coming back to haunt you but over
time like you do get less cringy about
things you don't in the instance of like
if you've done something embarrassing a
week ago that cringe burn is still going
to be there like your cheeks are still
going to go deep red from doing
something and that's good that means in
the space of a week you regret doing
something but over time like I don't
regret things I did years ago so I don't
remember doing them you know I
remember any of the things I said to
ex-boyfriends or anything like a lot of
cringe unis an embarrassment is short
term I think that's very important to
remember
you know just write it out yep just
write it out embrace it and just say I'm
not doing that again draw a line under
it and just keep going you know yeah
absolutely that went on sorry I I
thought I knew what was talking about
and then I just had like a 10 second
silence while I was trying to buffer
buffering my brain that's why I pull it
that's why we can edit podcast I think
it's time for the news it is it is do
you have any AFC Wimbledon news for us
oh I do
basically AFC Wimbledon is a football
club and it's my favorite football club
it's one that I have personally followed
for all of my life I definitely heard of
it before John did something with them
um although I would like to say and I
think this is very obvious to anyone who
lives in the UK and listen to this no
one has heard of AFC Wimbledon
apartments John Green no one on this
planet I live in this country and I had
never heard of them in the UK football
pretty much if everyone in UK who likes
football supports a club in the Premier
League which is like the big league you
know I don't know what you guys would
call it but like the big players yeah
big league you know you got like the
Miami Dolphins I think right is that
thing Chicago's I honestly don't know
yeah but that kind of thing right so
like everyone who supports who likes
football will support the club that is
closest to them even if it's not close
to them at all like I'm from like I said
place called Essex and the closest
geological Club to us you're out the day
she's the closest geological Club to us
is a club called West Ham West Ham
United and there's nowhere near me it's
miles out but it's the closest Club
that's in the Premier League
so most people in Essex will support
West Ham you know very little people
support small clubs so I think it's
great that John's doing that genuine
thing I really do but no one's heard of
them so so that's the thing if you're in
anything below like Ligue 1 which is I
think they're I think AFC women is in
Ligue 2 or something we have no one
watches and no one
yes that's forsaking their I worry that
John as the only person turns up the
matches but I will tell you the news
about them which I I went down to AFC
Wimbledon myself and I got this news
direct from the source um I like I could
I click the link that you emailed me so
basically from what I can gather from
from this week's exciting AFC Wimbledon
news which hopefully John will be able
to clarify in the next podcast from what
I can gather AFC Wimbledon put in a
request for planning permission to build
a new stadium quite a while ago like a
few months ago I think like November
last year and they have been recently
making a couple of changes to the
original plans that they submitted so so
I guess they would have you know said
this is the city wanna build oh wait no
we're going to do this to it and I think
by looks of it there were there were a
few people around the local area who
lived near the stadium who were kind of
like well we don't want you to do this
so I think they've made some revisions
and it's causing some sort of
controversy but I heard that John
himself is going to fly out and make
some videos with the people who are
upset about this development and mostly
convince them that it's a good thing
that's what I heard
John I'm sure you'll be able to to do
that but basically a statement on AFC
Wimbledon's official website revealed
that the London borough of Merton will
shortly be conducting a further
consultation and adding this additional
information to the council website I
love this so much it's so exactly as
weird and esoteric as normal AFC
Wimbledon news this is it is actually
news is this a thing the John Key this
as far as I can I kid I looked I tried
to find some AFC Wimbledon news and this
is all I could find that seemed like
like actual as close to news as I could
get although I would say a very
important point on this development of
this stadium for a club that no one has
heard of the changes that we made the
Planning Commission primarily relate to
the basement ground and podium level of
the residential blocks which I assume
means that people live in the state
which I would not recommend because
football players practice all hours of
the day and you don't wanna be kicked in
the head at five o'clock in morning with
a football the north south street and
the east and elevation of the stadium so
I can also imagine that they just want
it to be really really tall on one side
so it's more like like slope rather I
mean they're gonna probably have
problems with the football rolling down
it but hopefully what they I think what
they're probably planning on doing is
putting the the away teams goal on the
bottom of the slope I can imagine that's
a good move cuz then the ball is gonna
build up momentum and just roll in yep
which is clever I genuinely hope that
the Dons which is there a colloquial
name are given this permission as a
lifelong fan of the Dons
I can only hope that this is the start
of something fantastic for the Dons any
my news and Mars news for the first time
opal has been found at a Martian
meteorite the meteorite in question was
blasted off the surface of Mars millions
of years ago it finally fell in Egypt in
1911 the tiny slice of the meteorite
provided two scientists for analysis was
found to contain fire opal opal fire
opal a mineral that tends to form here
on earth around hot springs hot springs
of course are perfect places for life to
form an opal could in fact potentially
trap microbes for a future examination
and expection inspection by us which is
pretty cool that's the Mars news and
that gemstone opal is likely created by
the interaction of water with silica
that's a good Mars really good good job
yes the planet near us um which is kind
of hot and dry it's basically a planet
of Utah it's not it's colder but it
looks hot it's red yeah that's that's
not but it hasn't got any water on it so
Howard but if it hasn't got any water it
must have gone somewhere because they
said that there was once proof of like
that they used to be rooted there's ice
on Mars there's ice underneath the
surface of Mars
polls kind of which kind of makes you
think okay well the waters evaporate
because it's hot
well it froze it's frozen it's frozen on
the frozen on the planet it's still
there it's frozen
well cute ah yeah it's both below the
surface because on the surface do you
want to know do you want to know the
answer to a question okay
this save she don't / I want it the UH
so Mars does not have a magnetic field
the way that Earth does so Earth has a
molten core or molten mantle and a solid
core and the core spins around and it
creates a magnetic field which deflects
a lot of high-energy solar particles so
that we are safer all right we have like
Etherea yes it's just like no go away
evil particles yes we also have a higher
much higher gravity we're like three
times more gravity here on earth than
they have they then Mars has I don't
know who they are the so those two those
two factors combined the fact that Mars
does not have a magnetic field because
it does not have a liquid mantle and
it's solid just to just solid all the
way through
Mars is I think with it actually we're
not sure about this we know that Mars
doesn't have a magnetic field but we're
not sure whether or not there is still
some molten bits of of Mars because
they're actually the the most recent
eruptions of the of the volcanoes of
Mars we're not that long ago see no
what's this way you're totally wrong if
it's a solid core how do they have
liquid magma huh I could answer that I
should go work at NASA
there's gotta be liquid stuff in there
if you got volcano we're stuff spurting
out of it
well the volcano hasn't been active in a
few million years but uh I'm not sure
how long I'm not sure how long it was
why don't we get into it okay if we can
like if we can slingshot fil-a onto a
comet why can't we drill into Mars well
maybe someday we will be able to why
call me now
hey it's why haven't you done this hi I
haven't finished explaining to you why
there's no water on the surface of Mars
fine fine explain um so that those two
things combined wouldn't because there
is no magnetic field and
the because the gravity isn't as as
significant solar wind can actually
actually like blows the atmosphere
regularly like knocks the the atmosphere
off the planet and into interstellar
space so there's a very thin atmosphere
on Mars it's very low pressure so any
water on the surface of Mars would even
if or ice in a lot of cases would
immediately sublimate so go straight
from the liquid form to the gas form and
then be in the atmosphere and then get
knocked off by the solar wind so all of
the first layers of Marsh Martian dust
is dry but we found that below the first
few layers where the atmosphere isn't
interacting with it as much
there actually is quite a lot of ice
right now it's like a sauna
it's very cold sauna with absolutely no
water vapor because it's all been
knocked into space and just enjoy
yourself get tan I think it sounds great
I might go if you're too scared to go
Hank cuz it's you're too scared I would
go a quarter Mars whatever all right
well I mean I hope that you use probably
kind of bad the it'd be Internet would
be a problem on Mars you'd have to bring
it with you okay that's a problem I
don't know how to stop service another
quick question about Mars you say it has
no magnetic field could we resurrect
life on Mars if we just made a spinning
ring of magnets and spun it around real
quick the planet uh it would help I
don't think that life would it just took
a fridge magnets stuck them together
wrapping around Mars like slightly
bigger than Mars bigger circumference
cuz then it can actually go around it
like a Saturn ring yeah we just spun it
around somehow like if we just like flew
a comment into it cuz we can control
comets now I just decided um would that
help because I mean then it could not
call that radiation and then maybe in a
few million years grass could grow and
then we could have that sheep on our
maybe nice that is I mean one of the big
concerns in the world of how do we
travel to Mars is the radiation because
it is not a safe place for humans to
exist on the surface of so possibly if
we went to Mars we would certainly have
to have radiation proof structures and
and
even maybe build build the the areas
where we would live underground to
protect us from that which doesn't sound
like very much fun just underground on
Mars yeah so you know I don't I don't
well when it first happened I mean if
you're talking about like right in that
in the basement of Chernobyl where like
the the bad stuff cause that's
definitely worse but you know around
Chernobyl I'm not sure if now Mars is
more radioactive than the surroundings
of Chernobyl I turn Obul exclusion zone
as they call it the area where you can't
go because it's still radioactive yeah
where that guide kind of thing takes a
lot see I know a lot I can physics tick
tick tick tick yes thing is you you said
you know they're sending people to Mars
right on a mission no no you you said
they were sending people there is a
thing they're sending people to Mars oh
right I don't know like there's there's
this there's this basically a private
organization that says they want to yeah
but don't haven't enough money to do it
trying to do it yes but you just said
that you pretty much fried to a crisp
so why right do that that's too huh well
I mean yeah stupid sorry if you have
radiation shielding you could you could
make it I think that part of the the
deal with that mission is that it's a
one-way trip and they expect the first
people to go to Mars to also be the
first people to die on Mars which is not
how the government would do it and also
not how I would do it and also not how I
think we should do it they should first
like like the Russians if that Sputnik
thing stand a dog like I don't yeah if
that one I thought is responding I don't
know if they send a dog and the dog
lives then we go or possibly a multitude
of dogs first that's I just well what I
like is the idea of just puppies just
Mars puppies I think people would ease
no crispy puppies that's sad well maybe
we'll genetics will jet will genetically
engineer the puppies so that they'll
live safely and happily on the surface
of Mars and then we'll go there and and
you know 30 years time and it'll just be
covered in small dogs it'll be great
another real thing you said miles is
code correct result
you up and crisps you so yeah yeah
radiation can if you're not used in
microwave it wants decided is different
would your phone to your ear so five
minutes is hot so surely they cancel
each other out
it's like having a really long phone
call like this one right this is a long
podcast as me just asking you why Mars
is and why Mars does yep yeah we should
we should we should do a new podcast
it's called who Mars are yeah I would
hang can Emma Island where you just you
just asked me questions about Mars and I
get increasingly exasperated oh oh oh I
had a question a genuine question that's
not just really stupid remember I sent
you on Twitter I say I don't if they
exiled the club members of AFC Wimbledon
to Mars who would be more mad you or
John I wouldn't be mad at all really
because the first people to colonize
Mars would be a relevant sports team not
leading scientists you know I mean I
mean John were pretty mad if all of the
football players for AFC Wimbledon were
exiled to Mars they would have had to do
something through bad but but I just
don't know who would be more mad you
know I think John I think John would
really really be very angry that AFC
Wimbledon lost their I lost their team
and I I would just be sort of happy that
anybody like watch any old person as
long as they're given the proper
equipment can can good science kids
oh it's just the football yeah I would I
would be I would be upset
I would I actually write I might be more
upset and I think that a lot of people
would be very very upset it just sort of
the the unnecessary expense of such an
exile yeah but I'm asking you who be
more upset you were John you want me
because you'd be upset for the sake of
humanity for the kick in the face to
science about it not being done properly
the you know the lack of what you know
the the loss of life and then you know
not being able to they're not scientists
and they can't report their findings
they're just the first humans on Mars
yourself and a reason you'd be pretty
mad Annie yeah I'd be pretty mad I'd be
pretty John would lose his entire
football team so it's a tough question I
suppose John I suppose John be more mad
and how mad can you really get yeah we'd
have to have him here to answer that
question we'd have we'd have to compare
our levels of anger
I hope John addresses this I hope I hope
so as well sweet I think that's
important that's the news section plus
all of my questions about Mars I could
have probably googled it really but you
win and I watch scishow and I like your
voice so I thought would be easy just to
ask you
I didn't definitely I didn't pay for
scishow episode I just got an absolute
Oh Thank You Emma for her guest hosting
this episode of dear Hank and John and
thank you all to the people who are
listening I hope that it was enjoyable
yeah it was good and if you'd like to
support scishow then you can go to
patreon.com/scishow
and I'm just used to outro on everything
you do and if you want to keep getting
smarter with us yeah you did that carbon
flash scishow and subscribe clips on the
mic but that was me genuinely freaking
out that I heard you say that I'm gonna
ask you to do that bit Khan you at
VidCon yeah I'm gonna ask you to film it
that's so good sorry good and you might
want to just do the intro the outro for
this cuz I don't know the difference
engines ran out too apparently alright
so happy now our theme music is Vai
gunnarolla the podcast is edited by
Nicholas Jenkins who's a big Emma
blackery fan I'll add you say hi to Nick
for us thank you if you have any
questions for us you can send those
questions to Hank and John at gmail.com
and as we say in our hometown don't
forget to be awesome
you